some of the best environments that have
ever existed in the destiny world
appeared in the dreadnought the massive
warship dungeon and personal hellscape
of oryx the taken king exploring the
dreadnought was the peak of the original
destiny as it was both a horrifying
place to find yourself trapped in and a
delightfully dense landscape full of
mysteries to uncover in the upcoming
destiny 2 expansion the witch queen
players are again delving into the
throne world of a deadly hive god with
savithun's throne world developer bungie
looks to be pushing even harder on
creating a twisted locale filled with
frightening threats and deadly secrets
we recently got a chance to see about an
hour of the witch queen in action during
a hands off preview in which bungie took
us through the new destination
demonstrated some elements about the
expansion story campaign and showed how
things such as weapon crafting will work
like most destiny 2 destinations
savithun's throne world consists of
locations you'll run through as part of
the story campaign as well as public
areas you can explore at your leisure
the place looks to be comparable in size
to the dreaming city or the dreadnought
it'll consist of three public areas
linked together each with larger
structures you can enter and depths to
explore the screenshots and videos of
the throne world that bungie has already
shown off consist of hive structures and
dungeons swampy areas and a cleaner
white city-like landscape destiny 2
creative director joe blackburn said
during the presentation that the throne
world is a reflection of sabathun's mind
and thus these locations manifest
elements of her personality the desolate
swamps and dark halls of hive dungeons
represents sabathun's past her years as
a hive god and the species dedication to
death and conquest those things are
being supplanted by her more recent
desire for the light which is
represented by the city and its
cathedral from what we saw that seems
like it'll make different areas of the
throne world feel very distinct from one
another and may even represent different
objectives as you explore in the city
area you'll find the lucent brood
sabithun's light infused hive enemies
these have different characteristics
than the usual hive enemies even if
they're not the light-bearing hive
guardians we've been seeing in the
marketing for instance break the shield
of a lucent hive enemy and rather than
it exploding that shield will transform
into a moth made of light and quickly
try to find another enemy to cling to
and power up before you can shoot it
down if you venture too close the moth
will instead attack you flying toward
you to explode like a bomb meanwhile the
swampier parts of the throne world are
populated by enemies that might have
been left behind by sabathun's adoption
of the light the darker portions of the
throne world contain enemies like the
scorn those who served sabathune before
but who aren't as convinced about her
change in ideology it all suggests a
throne world that might be at war with
itself reflecting internal struggles
with sabathune that lines up with the
lore we've seen in the last year which
has shown sabathune struggling with
conflicting feelings bungie also showed
off a new mechanic that drives your
explorations of the throne world called
deep sight it allows guardians to see
things that are hidden in the throne
world whenever they interact with
specific nodes in the preview we saw
deep sight reveal platforms and pathways
since a big theme of the witch queen is
doing psychic detective work as bungie
has described it the deep sight mechanic
might be about more than just revealing
invisible platforms back in september
blackburn and justin truman destiny 2's
general manager described the witch
queen as containing the definitive
destiny 2 campaign and we got a sense of
what that means in action during the
preview as in past expansions starting
up the witch queen will throw you into a
story campaign that consists of multiple
quests each unlocking as you complete
the last these quests are going to see
major changes from past expansions
however blackburn wouldn't put much of
an exact length on the campaign in terms
of hours although he called this the
meatiest campaign in a long time in
destiny 2 and said it would clock in as
longer than that of beyond light the
additional length comes from bungie's
efforts to make the story missions
bigger and more involved than in the
past in fact story missions are
borrowing more from end game content
like raids and dungeons they'll
challenge you more and dish out more
rewards than past story missions have so
while they'll be longer it sounds like
they'll be worth replaying the added
rewards come in two flavors first story
missions consist of the usual run from
point a to point b structure we've seen
in the past at intervals though you'll
run into what bungie calls major
encounters these are moments like a boss
fight in a dungeon or a raid and you'll
know you're in for a challenge when you
see them the arena you'll be fighting in
will be obvious you'll be able to drop a
rally banner at the beginning of it to
refill your ammo and ability energy and
you'll get a chest for completing them
blackburn said story missions tend to
have two or three major encounters
although that count isn't uniform across
all of them so you'll be earning lots of
gear as you fight through the story the
second means for getting rewards is to
play the campaign on the new legendary
difficulty which will be about as tough
as legendary dungeons and raids and will
dish out more and better rewards bungie
said it believes destiny 2 veterans will
be able to solo the legendary version of
the story at the witch queen's launch
although it will be difficult the good
news is that the campaign features
selectable missions so you can switch
between difficulties as necessary with
the challenge scaling automatically with
the size of your fire team in fact you
will want to complete the campaign on
legendary eventually bungie said doing
so will earn you some additional rewards
although the developer didn't say what
they'll be
the witch queen isn't the only story
that'll be unfolding in destiny 2 at
launch as it has in the recent past
bungie is also launching the first
content season of 2022 alongside the
expansion which we now know is called
the season of the risen it dovetails
with the story of savithun's throne
world the lucid brood have appeared hive
guardians are on the loose and the solar
system at large is responding to this
new threat in fact the first person to
come to the vanguard's aid when these
new hive appear is keital the cabal
empress back in the season of the chosen
the vanguard and the cabal came to an
uneasy truce it looks like that
diplomacy has paid off although we have
no idea what the details of the story of
the season of the risen will be we do
know that you'll be getting some cabal
themed gear however the preview showed
off a couple of the new cabal guns for
the season and it appears that the
exotic weapon grand overture is also a
cabal weapon mimicking the missile
barrage of the cabal colossus enemy the
addition of origin traits the new perk
unique to specific sets of guns based on
where they come from means that the
cabal themed guns in the season of the
risen will have a new perk called land
tank that should be pretty useful to
players taking on tough content during
the early portion of the witch queen as
the trait will give you higher
resilience and damage resistance as you
rack up final blows with that gun we
don't know much else about the season of
the risen but it does suggest that like
the time loop in the dreaming city we'll
be dealing with what's going on in
sabathan's throne world for quite a
while among the other major additions to
destiny 2 with the witch queen is the
enclave where players will engage in the
new weapon crafting system the enclave
is a new physical location on mars which
somehow returns after somehow vanishing
at the end of season of the lost mars
won't be a large playable area but will
instead be similar to what phobos was
during the taken king expansion of
destiny 1. it looks to function a bit
like your base of operations for the
expansion and also houses a darkness
artifact called the relic which is where
weapon crafting takes place bungie
showed us a bit more about how weapon
crafting will work expanding on the
recent this week at bungie blog post
that ran the system down in order to get
guns you can craft you'll need to unlock
patterns to get those you'll hunt for
random drop versions of the guns you
want ones that have a red border on
their icon
this means the weapon comes with deep
sight resonance which is the key
requirement to crafting the deepsite
resonance guns come with objectives to
complete by using them which will have
you taking on activities and racking up
kills completing those objectives will
either earn you a pattern for the gun or
currency that you'll use for crafting
once you have a pattern you can craft
your own version of the gun and then add
the perks you want to it although not
every gun can carry every perk much like
the random rules you get on weapons
right now you'll also need to use the
crafted gun in order to level it up and
as you do more perks will become
available to it it seems like there will
be a lot of currencies involved with the
crafting system we counted at least four
during the presentation although it's
not clear what they all do or how tough
to acquire they'll be destiny has
definitely had issues with including
tons of confusing super specific
currencies in the past so that's a
potential drawback with the crafting
system we'll have to see how it actually
feels and functions by playing it and
like everything in destiny 2 it's
entirely possible bungie will adjust it
once players have had it in their hands
for a bit if the currencies get unwieldy
you should also know that not every
weapon will be craftable at the launch
of witch queen but there are no time
gates or upper limits on how many
weapons you can craft at the relic the
only limiting factor is how many
materials you have blackburn said bungie
isn't looking to make weapon crafting a
situation that's about making 10 000
daggers just to get one good one instead
you're going to be making very
deliberate choices about the weapons you
make and bungie wants you to develop a
relationship with that weapon the
crafting system will even track the date
you shaped your gun and will note its
level as you use it what's more the
relic allows you to craft guns to shape
them and then to recraft or reshape them
in essence you won't have to keep three
or four copies of the same gun with
different perks in your vault just in
case one roll ends up becoming meta when
bungie makes changes to the destiny 2
sandbox instead you can take the one gun
you made that you like return to the
relic and change its perks around with
the reshape option it's still the same
gun you've come to love but crafting
will allow it to be adaptable to changes
in the game finally we got a very quick
taste of bungie's coming adjustments to
the void subclasses the first set of
changes that are coming to the light
classes that have been part of destiny 2
since its release when bungie released
stasis with beyond light it also
introduced a new more involved user
interface for the subclass that allowed
for greater customization with elements
called fragments and aspects that system
is coming to the other subclasses
although one at a time and the first up
is void the new void interface looks
almost exactly like the stasis one and
it sounds like it'll function in the
same way with players earning aspects
and fragments to further customize their
subclasses to their playstyles in its
witch queen vidoc bungie devs joked that
all players will now be able to use
suppression grenades and to some degree
elements that used to be reserved to a
certain class are being democratized to
all through the use of aspects and
fragments we don't have too many other
details on the void 3.0 system but
bungie noted that players who've been in
the game for a while will have instant
access to everything they currently use
to make up their void subclasses in
other words you won't need to re-unlock
your standard void grenades or melee
attacks you'll have them as soon as you
log into the game as for the newer
editions bungie isn't going to gate them
too hard for players who've been in the
game for a while there will be a place
in the tower you can visit to upgrade
your void subclass for currency so you
won't have to go on lengthy quests to
earn the new elements coming to the
system you'll be able to enjoy it
quickly but we're not yet sure who
you'll have to visit or what you'll need
to spend to get these new void elements
there's a whole lot about the witch
queen we don't yet know but bungie's
preview event at least gave a sense of
what the new expansion will be like the
additions to weapons and classes look
like significant improvements and there
will be plenty to uncover in savithun's
throne world guardians will have to
uncover anything more than that by
themselves when the witch queen launches
on february 22nd
you